- Sikhism is the world's
fifth largest religion.
A Sikh's uniform, right,
a beard and turban
and all the articles of faith,
when I wear them, I'm
representing equality,
justice, fairness, and I’m telling the world
that this is what I stand for and this
is what I will fight for.
A Sikh would rather lose his
head than lose his turban.
I'm Simratpal Singh, I'm
a captain in the US Army,
and I'm also a Sikh.
- To attention.
- May gates.
- When I found out that I could not serve
with my articles of faith,
that was a shock to me.
Sikhs and military
service go hand in hand.
My great-grandfather served in World War I
for the British Indian Army.
There is no conflict
between what Sikh values
are and the army values.
I started my military career at West Point
when I was 18.
I knew I was gonna have
to make a big decision
of walking away from my articles of faith.
The grooming standards, as far as shaving
were codified so that
every one of the military
soldiers looked the same.
And I was standing in line
right outside the barber shop
and I’m thinking, ‘well, here it is, right,’
and I sat down and the ladies
at the barber shop were surprised.
I had long hair.
I had hair all the way to my back.
I don't know if they
understood what was going on.
My entire life was changing.
Everything, my self image,
everything was being shattered.
And that's when I had to
make a decision, right?
And the decision I made was I wanna choose
to serve my country and figure out a way
to come back to my
articles of faith later on.
(gentle instrumental music)
It was after I met the two
gentlemen who were wearing
their articles of faith
and were in the Army
that I learned there is a way
to request religious accommodation.
I was simply asking for what
I believed were my rights.
And March 31st was when I received
the permanent accommodation.
And I had to pause, 10 years later,
10 years later it had finally happened.
The first day that I wore my uniform
with my beard and
turban, it was an unreal,
unreal feeling.
When I look in the mirror now,
I feel a sense of pride and completeness.
My two worlds have come together.
(dramatic instrumental music)